part two of we played a bad prank in  high school by tping our own quarterback  and blaming it on the rival school  basically though when we found out that  the administration was trying to figure  out who did it the volleyball team went  silent we did not tell anyone anything  like there were girls on the team that  were dating boys on the football team  and they didn't even tell their  boyfriend we heard that coaches from the  other school were questioning the  players saying that they're going to  figure out who did it but obviously  nobody admitted to it because none of  them did it and we kept her mouth shut  and 10 days later the football team beat  them by like 60 points and the real  story never came out until today